so you may have heard the whole brouhaha
about country star Jason Aldean he well
let me read this this long tweet
that'll explain what's going on the
whole thing's so stupid here we go uh in
the past 24 hours I have been accused of
releasing a pro-lynching song a song
that has been out since May and was
subject to the comparison that I direct
quote was not too pleased with the
Nationwide BLM protest these references
are not only meritless but dangerous
there is not a single lyric in the song
that references race or points to it and
there isn't a single video clip that
isn't real news footage and while I can
try and respect others to have their own
interpretation of a song with music this
one goes too far as so many pointed out
I was present at Route 91 where so many
lost their lives and our community
recently suffered another heartbreaking
tragedy no one including me wants to
continue to see senseless headlines or
families ripped apart try that in a
small town for me
refers to the feeling of a community
that I had growing up where we took care
of our neighbors regardless of
differences of background or belief
because they were our neighbors and that
was above any differences my political
views have never my political views have
never been something I've hidden from
and I know that a lot of us in this
country don't agree on how we get back
to a sense of normalcy where we at least
go a day without a headline that keeps
us up at night but the desire for it too
but the desire for it too that's what
this song is about okay so in essence
the guy puts out a song back in May
nobody cared about it for months or it
was doing perfectly fine right like it
was doing just fine but nobody thought
of it as controversial then out of
nowhere it becomes the super
controversial thing and he's a racist
and he should be canceled and all of
this other craziness and listen to the
way the main it's very obvious this guy
is not a racist right we've been through
this guys right like rinse and repeat
we've been through this before someone
says something that is roughly true you
get told you're a racist and a
misogynist then a trans woman a
homophobe and everything else but watch
the way the mainstream media is treating
this story here are the well I'll put up
the warning here are the crazy women at
the view and here's Whoopi and no Whoopi
doesn't even know what she's watch the
way she's reading this thing she doesn't
even know what she's saying or why she's
outraged but she'll say it
so country singer Jason Aldean is
getting backlash for the video of his
song not in a small town which critics
are saying is racists Got lyrics racist
lyrics and images
Aldean says the songs about Unity listen
I listen you know there are lyrics in
the song and I think
you know he talks about life in a small
town and it's different you know and he
shows these images he's got uh folks
uh from the black lives matter movement
and he's talking about people taking
care of each other and I find it so
interesting that never occurred to Jason
or the writers that that's what these
folks were doing they were taking care
of the people in their town because they
didn't like what they saw just like you
talk about people taking care of each
other in small towns we do the same
thing in big towns you just have to
realize that when you make it about
black lives matter people kind of say
well are you are you
talk about black people and
unfortunately this became the number one
song on U.S iTunes we have a problem in
this country about race and the biggest
problem is we refuse to admit that it
exists well don't you think a lot of
this big city small town businesses
racist is about racism the cities have
more black people than the small towns
she has no idea what she's talking about
she's never listened to the song I just
read the statement from the guy also
what is she talking about that the
people in essence she's saying oh the
people in the big cities who burn down
the cities it was because they were
taking care of their communities tell
that to the people at Foot Locker and
Pep Boys you know what I mean it's like
what it's just nonsense it's like pure
nonsense to pretend that he's racist
because he grew up in a place where they
took care of each other